has it always been that your political
leaning has then been taken as the
foundation upon which the rest of your
person is built that that has been more
than norm in in history I think that
then what we've been used to until
recently which it which is more of an
aberration I think I mean it's sad as it
is to say I think that what what you're
referring to now which is becoming more
dominant is something of a return to to
the normal in history where people have
been less tolerant perhaps of
differences of opinion where people's
political views have been more closely
linked to fundamental things like
religion identity and that sort of thing
I think if you look at history you'll
find that that's more than norm and that
we've sort of gotten used to in recent
history that not being the case but I
think we're going back to that to some
degree and that's maybe what's causing
the temperature to go up in political
debate and the reluctant reluctance in
some quarters to tolerate differences of
opinion
I'm joined by graham Gerard and we're
gonna learn how to think politically
today right that's correct yes indeed
yes welcome to the show how are you
today thank you very much yes so glad to
be here yeah it's gonna be interesting
we've been delving into politics in
history a little bit recently on the
show so the listeners should be in the
mood for it at least appetites that have
been wet so to begin the discussion in
its purest form what is politics and why
do we need it
well politics is a way of managing human
societies
that uses argument debate rhetoric
persuasion but doesn't resort to use of
force it's uniquely a human thing
because we have language when when
shooting breaks out then politics ends
and you have war not everyone accepts
that view though there are lots of
different conceptions of what politics
is but really generally that's what it
is some of your viewers may be familiar
with that quotation it's often used by a
theorist of war German theorists worn
into closets who said that
war is just politics by other means so
that's a view of politics that I'm
rejecting my view is that when when war
begins politics ends it's not always
clear where the boundary is between the
two but that's a view of politics that I
have so politics is obviously important
if you want to resolve differences in a
way that doesn't resort to force
so all human societies involve some
element of agreement and sell some
element of disagreement if you didn't
agree on anything you wouldn't have a
political community at all to start with
right but if you agreed on everything
you wouldn't need politics so politics
lies somewhere between those two
extremes people agree and disagree and
so politics is really about how
you manage those disagreements so that
takes all kinds of different forms so
the one we're most familiar with is
democracy although even that takes
different forms but there are other
forms of politics that aren't democratic
indeed most of human history has been
characterized by forms politics that are
not democratic
in fact the the greatest democracy of
them all perhaps was ancient Athens and
then for almost 2,500 years there really
wasn't any democracy to speak of then it
was reborn in the 18th century 19th
century and now it's the dominant form
in large parts of the world but you know
there other form so in the particular
form of democracy that we know best in
the West in the modern West we have
institutions that we use to manage
society to allow us to cooperate to
pursue our common ends but also allow us
to manage conflict difference when we
disagree so that we're not killing each
other but you know there are other forms
as well so you know there's four terian
forms of politics and aristocratic forms
etc etc but in the general terms as I
said it's really about managing
societies in a way that avoids actual
violence I can't remember the first
person who I heard said it but the
comment that you made about you've got
discussion and you've got conflict you
have word and you have fighting words
and yes I suppose you know it's really
the only two ways that we can
communicate with each other right
it's either by talking about something
and then when that doesn't happen it
goes into it goes into fighting about
something there's not really there's not
really many other mechanisms that we
have to play with not really I mean they
say that there it's a sort of continuum
and it's not always clear where one ends
and the other begins when when does war
really start it's hard to say sometimes
but notwithstanding that I think you're
right I think that basically
it's one or the other you can talk about
it or you can fight about it and that's
yeah that's right that's right and of
course there are lots of different ways
to talk about it you can have a rational
discussion an argument try and persuade
someone but you know politics is also
about other forms of language rhetoric
and manipulation propaganda so those are
ways of trying to get people to your to
take your view without actually using
force it's not it's not our words can't
be weaponized as well right it's just
the it wasn't involved punching someone
in the face with them that's right
exactly exactly right
yeah it can be it can be you know words
can be highly manipulative and can
involve elements of a threat as well so
that's why the boundary is unclear but
to give maybe one example let's say in
in this country in Britain when in the
17th century a time of Thomas Hobbes a
philosopher Thomas Hobbes the Parliament
was at odds with the king
King Charles first and you know they
attempted to convince each other of
their respective views and they used
every manner of means but and eventually
it didn't work and they resorted to
civil war and when when civil war begins
as it did in this country in the 1640s
then you know you're no longer really in
politics you're into a different realm
where you're not trying to persuade
anyone you're trying to coerce them
through through fighting but of course
that has to end at some point and
politics has to resume so there that
would be an example the examples all
through history where politics breaks
down and in poor begins again it's it
could be civil war could be war between
states as well so how did politics and
power relate to each other right so
power is an aspect of politics it's a
key aspect fundamental aspect
power is always present in politics it's
present in other realms as well it's not
unique to politics all politics involves
power but not all power involves
politics so politics is as I said as a
way of dealing with power and so people
have conflicting interests they have
conflicting values they have conflicting
ways of approaching things and in a
world of scarcity where not everyone can
have everything they want they have to
resolve these differences and so this is
what politics is essentially about so
obviously to achieve things you need
power and as I say where people disagree
then they want they they want access to
power so they can achieve their own ends
the ends the ends they prefer so Paul a
large part of politics is is you know
struggle over power because power is the
means to attain these ends but not it
not everyone agrees on the ends and so
they disagree about you know they fight
over power so that's that's a key part
of politics but one of the points I make
in this book my co-author and I is that
that isn't the whole story and indeed
that's one of our main objectives in the
book is to show that polity hour is key
to politics but isn't everything and
there is a certain view of politics
which we reject which says that it is
just about power and there is another
dimension that's missing from that view
you could call that view the Francis
Urquhart view or they Frank Underwood
view the house you know the house of
cards view yeah it may be the
Machiavellian view that it's a Justice
from it's just a struggle for power but
we think that leaves out a huge
dimension and so there is a way of
talking about politics in addition to
that because course that's all true
that's a tricky part of an understanding
politics but this other dimension
is missing from that view and that
dimension has to do with concepts of
justice ideas values in that sort of
thing and we think that our proper and
complete view of politics has to include
both we refer to both power and to
justice to might and right and I think
that's a more complete view and really a
more human view of politics why do you
think that power is a term and she's
thrown around so much at the moment in
relation to politics well because I
think when people really diverge and the
degree there's always divergence in
politics between people what they want
their values their beliefs but they're
sometimes moments in history when the
divergence becomes very acute and and
and fundamental differences open up and
I think that when that happens the the
intensity of the struggle for power may
increase because there's so much at
stake when there's a sort of lot of
broad consensus then there's still some
amount of conflict not you know
nonviolent conflict but when the stakes
go up when there's major disagreement
about fundamentals then I think the
contest becomes more intense passions
are inflamed and people's even people's
sense of identity becomes a matter of
debate as we've seen with brexit I I was
hoping I wouldn't mention brexit this
quickly and so I think that may account
for some of the reason that and also
there is a there's a there is a view now
that people don't trust politicians as
much as they have in the past and now
what no one's ever really trusted them
that much but I think levels levels of
trust have gone way down this is borne
out by by surveys and things and I think
in that case people become more jaded
and more cynical and tend to see just
the power
specs of politics so that it's
interesting what you say about the the
identity thing so I've had a number of
political commentators on recently
Andrew Doyle who is the the man behind
this Hani McGrath Twitter account
described discussing who's actually
Banshees on a seven-day ban at the
moment or for something else this time
and yeah the the fact that you can no
longer have a political ideology which
isn't a comment on you as a person it's
not that you have you are a small
business owner therefore you're looking
after your interests it's oh no hang on
you voted you leaned right
therefore you are this sort of a person
and has it always been that way
has it always been that your political
leaning has then been taken as the
foundation upon which the rest of your
person is built that that has been more
than norm in in history I think that
then what we've been used to until
recently which it which is more of an
aberration I think I mean it's sad as it
is to say I think that what what you're
referring to now which is becoming more
dominant is something of a return to to
the normal in history where people have
been less tolerant perhaps of
differences of opinion where people's
political views have been more closely
linked to fundamental things like
religion identity and that sort of thing
I think if you look at history you'll
find that that's more than norm and that
we've sort of gotten used to in recent
history that not being the case but I
think we're going back to that to some
degree and that's maybe what's causing
the temperature to go up in political
debate and the reluctant reluctance in
some quarters to tolerate differences of
opinion so Jerry needs a little bit of a
step backwards I think it is myself we
tend to take it for granted because it's
what we're used to if you're beyond a
certain age anyway
me but I think if you put it in the
bigger perspective you see that it's
that that the abnormality is is the kind
of tolerance and civility that we had
until fairly recently which is now seems
to seems to be declining and I think
evidence for this I mean there's lots of
evidence for it but I give you a couple
of examples one of the themes in the
book is the the risks that political
thinkers have taken so history in
propounding their views often
controversial views so it starts with
Socrates who was executed by the
Athenians which was a democracy after
all fairly by the standards of the time
fairly open society relatively speaking
and yet they put him to death they
forced him to drink hemlock for his
political views is not for anything he
did but for what he said in public and
from that point on you see almost every
major political thinker right up until
the 19th century suffering some kind of
consequence for propounding their views
that either were killed or they were
tortured like Machiavelli was tortured
or they were forced into exile like John
Locke for example our Karl Marx or
George Abruzzo so that gives you some
idea of how intolerant the public sphere
has tended to be in history to the up to
people propounding views that are
considered heterodox and and
unconventional and so it's really only
from around the time of the
Enlightenment and onwards that people
have taken a more relaxed view in the
West towards this sort of thing but so
that one view is that that period which
of Greater tolerance of difference
differences of opinion is declining and
we may be entering a period when when
we're going back to the way it used to
be that's debatable it's controversial
but this certainly some evidence for
that
yes bizarre isn't it that we've were
currently framing a slightly more
conflict centered environment for
politics up against a unrepresentative
Lee Placid that's the period that we
went through just before but I taken
with a slightly broader range view over
the last 2,500 years or so this is it's
just par for the course or more
representative of what we've been used
to one of the things that you mentioned
there Socrates died in the story that
you put in the book a chaps that he
loved was when he got convicted by the
court he is convicted and before before
he was sentenced he said okay that's
that's great thank you for convicting me
now where's my reward he considered
himself worthy of a reward hadn't he for
the I tried come here with and I just
thought like he's such a ballsy move did
you say he was grotesquely ugly as well
well reports said he was yeah well we
have no real way of knowing other than
through accounts but he's reputed to
have been outwardly ugly but had a
beautiful soul and in the contrast is
with his friend and lover Alcibiades who
was a bad boy of the ancient world and
came to a sticky end as well but he was
famously externally beautiful handsome
but inwardly had a corrupt soul and so
the way that the two have been presented
as contrasts in in the writings of say a
Plato then yeah that submit but whether
that's just a kind of dramatization on
plato's part hard to say but yes that's
how that's how he's often been seen and
it has a it he's making plato's making a
point there and emphasizing this because
he wants us to see that what really
matters is that is the beauty of your
soul or the purity of your soul the
goodness of your soul not
things it's one of Plato's major themes
it's a theme that comes out in a lot of
ancient thought like stoicism and things
so he's whether Socrates really was all
that ugly or not it's it we'll never
know as I say but it serves a point that
Plato's trying to make hmm but I think
what do you think Donald Trump would how
would his speeches go if he started
talking about the beauty of people's
souls well hard to imagine that kind of
speech if he was making it yeah I mean I
don't know that Trump would be able to
reflect on that level about such things
that said I don't think very many
politicians would be and I think point
would probably be lost on most of them
so the big question you've covered 3030
yes individuals in this book yeah you're
out for dinner and you need to choose
five of the individuals that you
researched to be sat around the dinner
table with you who are you gonna choose
and why
right okay that's tricky one that's a
hard choice today's like choosing your
favorite child isn't it yeah exactly
exactly Sophie's Choice yeah Sophie is
Sophie's Choice for philosophers okay
well I mean there were there were a
personal aspect to it one of them would
have to be jean-jacques Rousseau the
Swiss philosopher of the 18th century
who lived during the French
enlightenment and who inspired all the
French revolutionaries they were he was
one of their hit biggest heroes mainly
because I've written about him and
studied him so closely so I have a
personal interest in that a plot it was
a very inherently strange and
interesting man what was strange about
he didn't fit into society the the
polite society that he inhabited in 18th
century Paris the world of Voltaire and
in the other philosophical world and he
preferred to live a life of austerity
he also may have had some mental
problems he had the tendency toward
paranoia and you know he was a difficult
man you know in most respects both on
principle and by virtue his personality
right who else would I be interested
well Socrates I mean Socrates Socrates
features in the book but of course
Socrates didn't write anything so it
would really be Plato so I would have to
include Plato as well I think just
because of the sheer range and depth of
his thoughts he just wrote about
everything and he did it all brilliantly
I'm not really a play I'm not a plate
honest but I mean five minutes with
Plato
I'd give a give a lot of I sacrifice a
lot to spend five table wouldn't get
bored would they you know that play if
Plato sat on the table there's always
going to be something else to have a
discussion about absolutely absolutely
it would be an exact he's almost
inexhaustible yeah so that would
certainly keep the conversation going I
don't think I don't think Rousseau would
be a good conversationalist but I was
gonna say what role do you think
Rousseau would play he'd probably be
smoking with me he'd be smoking over the
far side complaining about complaining
about the survey or something yeah I
would he'd be complaining about
something anyway we'd be disagreeing
with people at least so um who else
would I include there well I think
Thomas Hobbes would would probably be on
my short list of a five again for the
power of his mind and his originality he
had a very acute and analytical mind and
had a very clear if rather stark view of
the world I think that would be really
interesting he had a huge range I mean
he was famous initially for writing
about mathematics and geometry and
things like that so he was really what
we would call Renaissance man in terms
of the range of his thought and so I
think he would be fascinating
person then I think he would have a lot
to say about them the contemporary world
as well what you would think
I think he'd feel a lot of indication
because you know he lived he lived
during the English Civil War and he
wrote his masterpiece Leviathan in
response to the English Civil Wars have
traumatized him and that's what prompted
him so he's a man who really saw
conflict as the is the human norm and
thought that that was the most urgent
and pressing issue so I think he would
look around the world today and see that
he had been proven right would it just
be a big I told you so I think it would
be a lot yeah I think to a large extent
it would be of course people you know
see what they want to see what they
called confirmation bias involved but he
would certainly be someone I think I'd
like to spend time with chat chat to
that's three fingers I think Karl Marx
would have to be on that list as well
I'd be in to meet him personally it was
a sort of larger-than-life figure and
the gregarious and bearish sort of man
in many ways larger than life but I say
what what is he actually like is a
personality cuz I know a very shallow
amount of his work I don't actually know
what what he was like as an individual
could he tell us about that yeah he was
formidable intelligent vastly well-read
extremely broad ranging as a mind he was
say reputation as being as somewhat
bearish and cantankerous as a
personality but also quite gregarious
disorderly he liked to drink in Corral's
with his mates he used to go on pub
crawls and get up to no good in that
respect
he was extremely unconventional he was
fearless he sacrificed in Norse amount
for his views and his family his lived
in great poverty in exile in London
and so therefore did his family so he's
very courageous man you had the courage
of his convictions so a very big complex
personality that would be I'm sure fill
a room and would probably dominate it
too and could be really fierce I think
as well he probably he'd probably be
good at make partnering with the
waitress to get the cheque down probably
be one site the foods come at the end
he'd he'd have a reason as to why he'd
this shouldn't be so expensive and this
shouldn't be yes we are right well here
you know he had a tendency actually to
be quite profligate with money his
friend
yeah his friend Friedrich angles kept
him afloat financially so it could be an
intellectual full-time intellectual and
he ended up spending quite a lot of
money on on Karl Marx who was very free
and spending it no it's his for someone
who didn't have much he spent it quite
freely but so I wonder if he would but I
mean he he was argumentative so he would
probably have put up a fight
he once applied for a job with railway
this is before British Rail existed when
the railways were private and he was
turned down for the job but one imagines
if he had been accepted for that as a
conductor on a train what that might
have like we might not have had the 20th
century might not have looked the way it
did but one could imagine him you know
trying to collect the tickets of the of
the well-to-do bourgeoisie on the trains
and you know telling them your ticket to
please you
bourgeois Pig or something like that so
he was a sort of angry man but he
thought he had good reason to be I got
you so we've got four who's who's your
final guest gonna be right well that's
now it gets really tough let's say let's
say Friedrich Nietzsche okay
[Music]
that's difficult you know it's to choose
but yeah I would say Friedrich Nietzsche
a law
of Nietzsche's very very popular now he
wasn't in his own lifetime he wasn't
wasn't very well well circulated when he
was alive not in the least he his books
didn't sell he had to publish them
himself he had to finance the publishing
of his own books in his own lifetime
books it now sell in the hundreds of
thousands he couldn't he couldn't get
published often and had to finance the
publishing himself he his response to
that was he said that you know if my
books don't sell don't blame me if there
are no fish in the sea he said you know
people weren't ready for them yet and in
the sense he was right he was a sort of
ahead of his time
so that's all changed and now he looms
very large I coaches who find his books
in in Airport book shops now libraries
and book shops grown under the weight of
his books so he he touches a chord in a
way resonates with readers now in a way
that he never did in his own lifetime
why do you think that is now really a
good question and very hard one to
answer I think he offered a diagnosis
about the malaise of modernity about the
crisis of Western civilization as he saw
it that centers around the idea of the
death of God the loss of belief the
beliefs that really sustained Western
civilization for 2,000 years were
starting to be really questioned in a
serious way in his own lifetime and that
induced a sense of of angst and he
expressed that very well very powerfully
in way that a lot of others didn't and I
think that his sense of the problem was
very cute a very profound and
interesting the problem with Nietzsche
is that the cure that he prescribed was
much worse than the illness the the cure
he prescribed was really quite a
disaster it appealed to the Nazi
for example but so I mean there's not
much to be learned from this cure but
from his diagnosis I think he's one of
the supreme diagnosticians of the of the
problems the malaise and problems of
sort of late modern civilization mm-hmm
yeah I've got Douglas Murray on in a
couple of weeks right talking about his
new book which I need to hurry up
reading which is over there and very in
he's delivering it the books hilarious
in a very hard-hitting way but one of
the things that he brings up is exactly
that the fact that this the breakdown of
the previous institutions that gave us
social cohesion that made us work
together that gave people a greater
sense of purpose I also recently went to
go and see Alain de Botton the guy
behind the school of life who if anybody
who is listening has the opportunity to
go and see him live unbelievably
compelling public speaker absolutely
fantastic I saw Jordan Peterson last
year and I would be prepared to say that
Alain was more engaging live which is a
real credit to him and I'll ended what
was talking about the same thing he
talked about the the crisis of a
meritocracy the fact that we're
disconnected from nature and from a
sense of grandeur and all of these sorts
of things it is interesting that as
society modernizes and we have more
convenience better health care people
are living longer we're not dying of
diseases there are these unpredicted and
expected side effects that come with
that I also I'd love to your thoughts on
this I was discussing a little while ago
about Maslow's hierarchy of needs
you know I said was that a Paleolithic
ancestor who was out on the plains who
was struggling to fulfill the bottom of
the foundation of that particular
pyramid probably isn't too concerned
about self-actualization or about the
existential dread of whether or not he
is spending his life in the service of
the greatest purpose that he can well as
soon as we flipped that particular
pyramid on its head and all of those
bottom things have been taken care of
I think that's where a lot of the
existential dread comes in that there is
so much convenience at the bottom the
problem is now of abundance not scarcity
hmm yeah that's very much
Nietzsche's view so Nietzsche attacked
his own civilization for being a world
of comfortable self-preservation
a really narrow sheepish world where
most people's lives involved they had no
tension in them
he used the analogy of a bow and arrow
he said that the bow of life in modern
Western decadent civilization was flabby
it wasn't taught there's no death no
tension in the bow because as you say a
lot of the the things that had
preoccupied humans through much of
history just getting by having enough
food to eat shelter those basic things
had by the 19th century by the late 19th
century for a lot of people have been
satisfied perhaps not completely and for
lots not but for those for whom it would
have been satisfied their minds as you
say turn to other things what's the
purpose of life the meaning of life and
Nietzsche was very contemptuous of well
of the English in general and of John
Stuart Mill who also features in the
book who was a utilitarian who believed
that happiness was the purpose of life
and Nietzsche said no it's not life has
other purposes and one of his
inspirations was some the the Greek
tragic poets of the ancient world
so Nietzsche thought that one of the
prices that we pay as a civilization for
having satisfied so many of these more
basic needs is a loss of that tension a
loss of tragedy a loss of drama a loss
of struggle and in the absence of those
we don't we can't achieve anything great
and our society our civilization won't
produce it's just a civilization of
mediocrity of as I said comfortable
self-preservation and that he thought
that was an ignoble form of life I think
I think that me and nature would
probably have quite a bit to agree on
everything even if you look at the
individual level rather than a societal
wide level or a nation statewide level a
lot of the things that make us feel good
involve periods of some sort of stress
so acupuncture map so it's discussing
this the other day
acupuncture mat so don't worry you've
seen them it's like a yoga mat but it's
got little spikes on it and you lie on
it and asked one of my friends because
there's all sorts of different claims
that are touted around on the internet
about these sorts of things one of my
friends I said well what what mechanism
do you think it's working on because
he's a doctor but he also thinks that
they're effective so what do you think
it's doing and he said it's the same as
everything else it's the same as doing
high-intensity workout it's the same as
having a cold shower it's the same as
going for a difficult run it is a brief
period of stress which allows the body
to reset its equilibrium to a better
state also it allows you to feel
discomfort on your own terms and that
discomfort on your own terms
then reframes other levels of discomfort
if you run a half marathon last weekend
what is a minor disagreement with your
colleague at work this week you're now
seeing things within this new frame and
it's interesting that that life of
comfort the flabby life of comfort I
think it encourages people to look at
small problems with such fidelity then
they then begin to grow and grow and
grow and then this has been enabled by
always-on communication and then this
has been exacerbated by echo chambers
online which is delivered by social
media and frictionless you know it when
you look at it through this lens of
history it really isn't that much of a
surprise that we are coming up against
these problems and the fact that
Nietzsche was able to see this with such
in so much advance is is pretty
impressive yeah I mean he was talking I
think about the the the the pathologies
of
Ave Ave as he saw it decadent
civilization a rich flabby indulgent
decadent civilization and he recoiled
against that but you know there's a
concept in psychology known as contrast
effect which says that that that the
human mind functions to some due to
considerable degree on the basis of
contrast that when they've done
experiments to support this in social
psychology that you know we understand
things and we experience things by means
of contrast so if you only lived in a
environment that had one temperature you
you wouldn't really understand the
concept of those different temperatures
it's the contrast between them that
gives meaning and definition to the
experiences and I think that's part of
what Nietzsche was getting at the basic
insight here being that you know a life
lived only one way is missing some key
element to understanding appreciating
what's good about that life as well as
what's missing and so I think is a
really fundamental insight in Nietzsche
at a psychological level not just at the
level of civilization but he was a
really acute psychologist better
psychologist the philosopher in my
opinion it was a pretty sloppy
philosopher very self-indulgent
philosopher but he he was a very
brilliant psychologist Sigmund Freud was
a believer that Nietzsche was a great
psychologist and I think he understood
this I think he was expressing the same
idea that you really need tension
contrast drama to really achieve things
in life and also to understand and give
meaning to things and even even to
experience them fully and properly you
mentioned that Machiavelli was suffered
through his thoughts
I haven't haven't heard that story would
you be able to tell us about that yes he
suffered quite horribly
it wasn't well it was less for his
thoughts then simply for his involvement
in politics he was a diplomat and a
civil servant in his working life until
you know in the Renaissance in
Renaissance Florence where he lived
politics was was a nasty game and if you
back the wrong side you suffered
consequences if your side lost and his I
did lose and he was kicked out of office
because he was on the losing side and
then he was arrested and then he was
tortured and and then he was exiled and
nearly killed in fact I think it's a big
laundry list of nasty things to have
given to you isn't it yeah well he took
it really well he's also you know he
took he wrote some amusing sonnets about
his being tortured the bit that that
that he had found the most difficult of
all those things was being exiled being
removed from politics because he was a
really a political animal he loved
politics he loved being in the fray in
the center of the storm of politics the
vortex of politics and he he took the
torturer reasonably well but he didn't
take the exile very well the exile from
politics then it was only after that
that he wrote his his books the books
for which he's most famous the prince
for example but these weren't published
in his lifetime and they were they
became nuria notorious later on but you
know that's why politics was was a play
to the game of politics was played back
then he understood that he knew the
rules of the game and he took it well
that's fun so one of the things that
you've been a consistent thing
throughout this discussion is a lot of
the political thinkers the scholars or
the statesmen that we've been discussing
have been real intellectual powerhouses
a lot of them have had been able to draw
from multiple different subject areas
Nietzsche not only doing philosophy also
doing psychology Aristotle Socrates
you know these I've got you've got
people that were economists master
economists and they then funneled this
ability into politics one of the things
that you brought up at the very
beginning in the book which I really
loved was talking about the difference
between knowledge understanding and
wisdom I think which was the three the
three different levels that you had to
to the way that people put knowledge
into action and the highest version of
its delivery to reality being that of
wisdom hmm is that something that
politicians should strive for because to
me now politics and a lot of the people
that are listening will think well it's
all sounds well and good but this is
kind of a archaic romantic view of what
politicians were there were these
armchair philosophers who didn't
actually have to deliver things and now
politicians to me appear much more like
Kings would have done perhaps in the
past does that make sense you know it
makes sense I understand that criticism
they're wrong so I mean in the
introduction to this book we make a
distinction between what we call naive
idealist s-- and naive realists and we
try to position ourselves somewhere
between the two so a naive idealist
would be someone of the type you've just
described who hasn't got a lot of
experience of real experience in
politics who's a bit otherworldly as
they're both feet firmly planted in the
clouds as it were and just sort of
prescribes things with no real sense of
reality so that's one extreme and you
know we don't think that's the right
view and the other extreme is is the
what we call naive realism the kind that
I started with at the beginning the
Frank Underwood the Francis Urquhart
view that ideas and values have really
no part to play at all that politics is
fear simply about power and interest so
we try to show that politics is vols
both aspects its power but the idea that
you can understand or be effective in
political life with without consider
that there are other things involved
than just power interest things like
ideas and values and beliefs I don't
think is makes people very effective
politicians and that's particularly the
case when you they come up against big
problems and if I can give a concrete
example I think a recent example I think
David Cameron is a good example of a
kind of politician he's in the Judas now
for his memoirs who who didn't really
have as far as I could see any really
clear conception of the role that ideas
and values playing in politics a kind of
very pragmatic politician now that's
fine in good times but when you're
confronted with really deep divisions
and problems of the kind that brexit has
opened up let's say or the rise of
populism in the West let's say then I
think you need to be able to understand
that people are interested in in issues
of identity of goals and ends and that
these necessarily play a part in life
they may not always play the same part
or a big part but they're always there
there's no way around it and I think
that that the the ideal of your politics
that combines an appreciation of both
it's it's it's a mixed form of of
activity it involves power and interest
on one side and ideas and values and
conceptions of justice and ends as well
means and ends and so people who say
well it's just naive to involve you know
to try and move politics in the
direction of the latter of ideas and
conceptions of justice that the ends and
purposes of life I think that's wrong I
think that we we need to rebalance our
understanding of politics so that it
involves both and that the politics the
quality of public debate would be
improved the understanding of political
life would be improved I think we've
moved too far in the in the into the
Frank Underwood view this the sort of
extreme cynical view of politics
couldn't couldn't agree more there that
the fact that politicians you know we've
given you the opportunity to sit down
with five people who were involved in
politics mm-hmm you've struggled to
choose those five right because you're
spoiled for choice you've got these
people who are unbelievable thinkers and
polymaths across all different areas of
thought now my conception of politicians
isn't that of someone that I look up to
with as a paragon of wisdom
I don't think oh my god I can't wait to
sit down with Boris Johnson I bet he's
got like such a unbelievable
understanding of the inner nuances of
the human human minds I don't i don't
think that i think that that lack of
aspiration equates to a lack of respect
on an individual level for a lot of
people who look up at these politicians
and yeah yeah that's definitely a
mechanism that i can see working
interestingly you mentioned about David
Cameron's memoirs did you see his
morning routine have you seen this no I
haven't so we're big fans of morning
routines on the show and we work quite
hard to come up with something that we
enjoy on a morning so presumably it's
something that he enjoyed but he spoke
about he would wake up on a morning and
he would have mackerel on toast and then
sit in a room for two hours and just
think David I'm not I I don't I don't a
critique it too much right you know you
did you've got yourself certainly
further in the House of Commons than I
about bought mackerel on toast and
sitting in a room on your own facilities
I'm not I'm not convinced that set you
up for a fantastic day of politics but
no I fell off maybe it was the mackerel
right well I don't know about that
maybe you should spend two hours reading
rather than thinking it doesn't seem to
produce a greater result in his case but
um you know I just just to your original
question I mean yeah we're not saying
I'm not saying that I want philosophers
philosophers to be kings
rulers to be thinkers I just think it's
it's not that I would expect the Prime
Minister to be well versed although you
know in the classics of political
thought although Boris Johnson
presumably has read of these because
he's a classicist himself but it's
rather that I think that the tone and
language of public debate that are that
surrounds politicians could be raised
and should be raised and that's one of
the purposes of the book to try and
maybe to some tiny little degree show
that we can discuss these things in
different terms and use different
language and I'm not naive enough to
think for one second that you know that
these active politicians can themselves
become you know political thinkers in
any sense but rather that the overall
context within which politics happens
could be elevated to some degree as I
say rebalanced a little bit in favor of
trying to think a slightly deeper level
maybe talk in more general terms and not
always be obsessed and preoccupied with
the horse race of politics well
certainly reading through how the thing
politically I was struck by the fact
that I have bizarrely I have more
respect now for politicians overall I
have more hope a little bit more hope
because there's some really good
examples right people of people who you
would want to lead your nation or you
would want to be at least contributing
to the discourse you know it's just a
hope that we get some more characters
that would make it into the pages of
this book at some point in the
not-too-distant future yeah I mean with
surprisingly few exceptions of those
thirty thinkers we profile with
surprising a few exceptions they all
were involved to a greater or lesser
extent in actual politics you know from
Confucius right on to the to the to the
present are very very few of them were
pure intellectuals surprisingly they all
were lived in her
world's where politics and ideas did
overlap and as I say most of them paid
some kind of price for that so you know
they weren't just completely isolated
from reality
they had a direct involvement in most
cases and that's part of where they
derived their views about politics and
so as I say III think I think it's
realistic to expect that the that people
like that should have some role to play
in public life in shaping the debate in
reflecting upon it and moving us as you
said from information to knowledge to
wisdom now I don't realistically expect
never get there in the actual practice
of politics but I do think there's scope
for improving and elevating the tone of
debate somewhat yeah I hope so too
well anyway Graham it's been absolutely
fantastic to speak to you thank you so
much for your time the link to how to
think politically will be in the show
notes below anybody who is interested to
go and check it out it will be linked
there plus any other resources that
we've gone through today
Graham they've been a real a real
interesting insight into the past of
politics I hope that we've opened some
people's eyes to a yeah world of
thinkers that are a little bit different
to what what's the thing at the moment
if only that then that it was well worth
the time and I really enjoyed it thank
you
[Music]